>> HAPPY TUESDAY, EVERYBODY.
OH, WE GOT A GREAT SHOW TONIGHT.
NIKKI HALEY IS HERE WITH US.
YOU KNOW, SHE HAS A NEW BOOK.
THE TITLE IS, IF YOU WANT
SOMETHING DONE, ASK A WOMAN.
AIN'T THAT THE TRUTH?
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
VACUUMING MY OFFICE, AM I RIGHT?
>> A SEXIST WOULD SAY.
>> THAT'S TERRIBLE.
VERY BAD.
BUT IT ALL FAIRNESS, A WOMAN DID
WRITE THAT JOKE.
WHICH IS PROOF IF YOU WANT
SOMETHING DONE, YOU GOT TO ASK A
WOMAN.
AND SHE WROTE IT PROBABLY WHILE
WATCHING ONE OF HER STUPID SOAP
OPERAS.
>> WOW.
WHAT ANOTHER SEXIST WOULD SAY.
>> I'LL STOP.
ALL RIGHT.
SO IF YOU'VE -- HAVE YOU SEEN
ANY GOOD MOVIES LATELY?
AND I DON'T MEAN THE ONE THAT
WENT VIRAL.
BUT IF YOU SAID NO, THAT'S YOUR
FAULT.
YOU'RE PROBABLY RACIST, SEXIST
OR EVEN A HOME MONTH PHOBE.
THAT'S HOW ACTOR BILLY -- OF HIS
GAY COMEDY DEBROS.
TRUE, I GET MORE VIEWERS WHEN I
LEAVE THE BATHROOM DOOR OPEN.
ALTHOUGH IT MADE GAY CINEMA
HISTORY, REPLACING BROKE BACK
MOUNTAIN WITH BROKE AT THE BOX
OFFICE, IT WAS A SO SPARSELY
ATTENDED, NO ONE GOT MONKEY POX.
>> A HOMOPHOBE WOULD SAY.
>> APPARENTLY, IT MADE $4
MILLION OVER THE WEEKEND.
THAT'S WHAT LARRY KUDLOW LEFT
THE WAITRESS AT THE CHEESE CAKE
FACTORY A FEW WEEKS AGO.
HERE ARE OTHER MOVIES THAT MADE
MORE THAN $4 MILLION.
THE LIFE IN TIME OF -- IT'S ON
NETFLIX.
YOU SHOULD CHECK OUT.
FINALLY, THE GOOD, THE BAD ENJOY
BAHAR.
I THINK WE HAVE A CLIP OF OUR
FAVORITE SCENE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> I I'M NEVER GOING TO STOP.
THE EXCUSE FOR THE MOVIE'S POOR
PERFORMANCE IS THAT STRAIGHT
PEOPLE DIDN'T WANT TO SEE HIS
GAY MOVIES.
AND IN THE REAL WORLD, NO PEOPLE
WANTED TO SEE HIS GAY MOVIES.
WHY?
BECAUSE HE CRAPS ON SO MANY
PEOPLE EVERY DAY, HE SHOULD BE
MAKING ONLY GERMAN PORN.
IF YOU GET THAT JOKE, YOU'RE
DISGUSTING.
TRUE, IF YOU DON'T EMBRACE HIS
NARROW POLITICAL VIEW, YOU ARE
EVIL WHICH MAKES UP ABOUT THREE
QUARTERS OF THE PLANT'
PL
POPULATION.
THIS IS THE GUY WHO IS MAD YOU
DIDN'T SEE HIS MOVIE.
>> IF THERE ARE ANY REPUBLICAN
WOMEN OUT THERE, SO MANY OF YOUR
HUSBAND ARE PRETENDING TO BE
STRAIGHT RIGHT NOW.
>> BUT MY FOCUS IS NOT ON TRUMP
VOTERS.
THERE'S TO WAY IN THE NEXT 48
HOURS I'M GOING TO MIRACULOUSLY
GET SOMEONE WHO'S RACIST TO, YOU
KNOW, BE NOT RACIST.
I AM SICK OF DONALD TRUMP.
I AM SICK OF EVERYONE THAT
ASSOCIATES WITH HIM.
>> I DON'T SEE THE APPEAL.
BUT, FRANKLY, HE REALLY IS AS
BAD AS OFFENSIVE AS A KITTEN
PLAY WITH A BALL OF YARN.
THERE'S TO RISK THERE, BUT
THERE'S SOME LESSONS HERE,
BILLY.
ONE, IF YOU PROMOTE A FILM
THAT'S IDENTITY SPECIFIC, YOU'RE
GOING TO EXCLUDE AS MUCH YOU
PRETEND TO INCLUDE.
YOU'RE TELLING THE AUDIENCE THAT
THIS IS FOR OTHERS, BUT MAYBE
NOT YOU.
IT'S TRUE WHETHER YOU DO A GAY
FLICK OR A DOCUMENTARY ON
SWITCHBLADE
SWITCHBLADES.
AFTER YOU SPEND YEARS
DETERMINING INSTEAD OF GROWING
AUDIENCES, YOU BLAME EVERYONE
BUT YOURSELF WHEN NO ONE SHOWS
UP.
THAT'S THE LONG-TERM EFFECTS OF
YOUR IDENTITY POLITICS OF YOUR
PERSONALITY.
NOTHING IS AT EVER FAULT.
IT'S ACTUAL THE ONLY THING THAT
IDENTITY POLITICS ACTUALLY
CREATES.
IT'S NOT AUDIENCES, IT'S
VICTIMS.
BUT ALSO BILLY GOT TRICKED BY
HOLLYWOOD'S PHONY SIGNALING TO
ACTUALLY THINK THAT HIS AUDIENCE
WOULD BE LARGER THAN IT IS.
SO IT'S NO WONDER THE THEATERS
WERE EMPTIER THAN A ROOM WHERE
THEY'RE TRYING TO SURPRISE
KAMALA ON HER BIRTHDAY.
SO AT LEAST THE TWITTER WHERE HE
BLAMES LACK OF TICKET SALES ON
HOME MONT
MOM /-* --
SHOWS ARE HIS PEOPLE BECAUSE HE
ALREADY DROVE AWAY EVERYONE
ELSE.
IT ISN'T TRUMP SUPPORTERS WHO
LET BILLY DOWN, IT WAS HIS
SUPPORTERS.
WHICH IS A GOOD THING FOR BILLY.
AS PEOPLE LIKE BILLY ON THE LEFT
ALWAYS STRESS, DIVERSITY IS SO
IMPORTANT AND YOUR MOVIE WAS
REJECTED BY A VERY DIVERSE
CROWD.
PEOPLE OF ALL STRIPES SAID SCREW
THAT NOISE.
TALK ABOUT UNITY, THIS COUNTRY
CAME TOGETHER AND SAY THEY
RATHER GET DENTAL WORK THAN SEE
THE MOVIE.
THAT'S PROBABLY ON ART BASE WITH
IDENTITY.
EVEN PEOPLE THAT IDENTIFY WITH
YOU MIGHT EVEN RESIST YOU.
IF HOLLYWOOD MAKES MOVIE THAT
ALIENATE THE PUBLIC, THAT'S ON
THEM.
YOU HAVE TO BE A LUNATIC TO BE
SURPRISED BY THAT.
>> LOOK, I KNOW YOU'RE UPSET
THAT YOUR MOVIE ISN'T DOING VERY
WELL.
BUT AS YOUR AGENTS, I THINK WE
NEED TO REREACCESS YOUR BRAND.
>> IN ALL WHITE PEOPLE FAULT.
HOW COME THEY DIDN'T SEE MY
MODIFY?
>> YOU ARE A WHITE PERSON.
ALSO, BLACK PEOPLE DIDN'T SEE IT
EITHER.
I DON'T THINK YOU CALLED IT
THINGS THAT YOU CALL THE FILM
WHITE PEOPLE REALLY SUCK.
THAT'S LIKE 70% OF THE COUNTRY
RIGHT THERE.
>> I DIDN'T MAKE IT FOR THEM.
>> NO, BUT IT DIDN'T HELP THING
THAT RIGHT BEFORE THE PREMIER
YOU TWEETED THE FOLLOWING PEOPLE
SHOULD NOT SEE MY MOVIE, WHITES,
MEN, GUN OWNERS, REPUBLICANS,
LIBERTARIANS, STRAIGHT PEOPLE,
WEIGHTLIFTERS, MEAT EIGHTERS AND
DUDES NAME KEVIN.
>> REPRESENTATION MATTERS.
>> IT CERTAINLY DOES.
AND THAT'S WHY WE CAN NO LONGER
REPRESENT YOU.
GOOD LUCK WITH EVERYTHING.
>> YOU'RE JUST SAYING THAT
'CAUSE YOU'RE WHITE, KEVIN.
[APPLAUSE]
>> SO HOLLYWOOD LOST THE PLOT
ONCE THEY MADE IDENTITY A
PRIORITY OVER ENTERTAINMENT.
THAT GOT BILLY THE MOVIE GIG BUT
IT DIDN'T GIVE THE AUDIENCE MUCH
MORE.
INSTEAD, YOU'RE LEFT WITH FILMS
THAT HAVE STRONG POLITICAL
SOCIAL AND CULTURAL MESSAGES BUT
AREN'T ENTERTAINING.
IT SOUNDS A LOT LIKE MY
DEFINITION OF PROPAGANDA.
BILLY, IF YOU WANT PEOPLE TO
COME SEE YOUR MOVIES, DON'T CALL
THEM LOSERS.
WHY NOT GET TO KNOW THE AUDIENCE
INSTEAD OF BROWBEATING THEM.
BUT THIS IS THE GUY THAT SAID F
TRUMP, F HIS WHOLE FAMILY, F
EVERYONE THAT CHOSE TO WORK WITH
THEM AND F EVERY SINGLE TRUMP
VOTER.
GUESS WHAT?
I'M STILL WITH HER, YOU
MISOGYNIST AMERICAN DUMMIES.
I GUESS, BILLY, YOU FOUND OUT
THE FEELING IS MUTUAL.
>> TONIGHT'S GUEST.
SHE'S SO SHARP, SHE GIVES
BALLOONS NIGHT MATTERS.
NIKKI HALEY.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THE BIGGEST LAUGHS GETS IT
FROM HIS DATING PROFILE, JAMIE L
LASALLE.
>> SHE'S 90 POUNDS SOAKING WET
AND FROM ALL OF THOSE SPILLED
MARGARITAS, KATHERINE TIMPF.
[APPLAUSE]
>> AND HE ACTS LIKE HE'S ABOVE
EVERYBODY ELSE, 'CAUSE HE IS.
MY SIDEKICK, TYRUS.
ALL RIGHT.
AMBASSADOR GOVERNOR.
DO I SAY AMBASSADOR GOVERNOR --
>> IT'S NICKY.
THOSE ARE MOMENTS IN TIME.
>> I LIKE THAT.
MOMENTS OF TIME.
THAT'S MY NEXT BOOK.
BY THE WAY, CONGRATULATIONS.
I LOVE THE COLOR.
>> THANK YOU.
>> IT'S A GREAT COLOR.
>> THE COLOR OF MY FRIDGE.
IT'S THE COLOR OF EVERY FRIDGE.
SO I HAVE A TOPIC -- WELL, THIS
IS KIND OF ALONG THE SAME LINES,
IDENTITY POLITICS.
DID SUNNY EVER APOLOGIZE TO YOU?
>> SHE DID NOT.
NEITHER DID HER PRODUCER OR
ANYONE ELSE.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF PEOPLE FORGET
OR REMEMBER, THAT SHE SAID YOUR
NAME NICKY WAS MADE UP AND THAT
WAS NEVER ON THE BIRTH
CERTIFICATE.
IT'S AN INDIAN NAME.
>> AND SUNNI IS NOT ON HER BIRTH
CERTIFICATE.
THE LADIES AT THE VIEW WHEN THEY
START TO ATTACK YOU, THAT'S WHEN
YOU KNOW YOU'RE WINNING SO I'M
OKAY WITH IT.
[APPLAUSE]
>> ISN'T IT INTERESTING THAT
ANYBODY WHO ASCRIBES TO THE
WORLD OF IDENTITY POLITICS
ALWAYS ENDS UP SEEING THEMSELVES
AS A VICTIM?
HE LOOKS AT THE PROBLEM INSTEAD
OF TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
PROBLEM IS.
IT'S EVERYBODY ELSE'S FAULT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND YOU KNOW THEN THEY GO AND
WHINE AND COMPLAIN ABOUT IT.
YOU CAN'T ALIENATE SO MUCH OF
THE POPULATION AND GET UPSET.
THE REALITY IS, THE MOVIE DIDN'T
LOOK FUNNY.
IT'S A LESSON FOR ACTORS,
MUSICIANS, ATHLETES.
STAY IN YOUR LANE.
STAY IN YOUR LANE, OTHERWISE
DON'T COMPLAIN WHEN THE MONEY
DOESN'T FLOW.
>> JAMIE, YOU HAVE NO LANE.
>> UH-HUH.
>> AND --
>> SPEAKING OF MONEY NOT
FLOWING.
>> YEAH.
THAT LEADS ME TO A QUESTION.
YOU CLAIM TO BE HETEROSEXUAL
ALTHOUGH HAVE A MISERABLE
MARRIAGE.
>> DAMN.
>> IF YOU WERE ASKED TO DO A GAY
SCENE IN A MOVIE, WOULD YOU DO
IT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
100% IF IT WAS FUNNY.
>> YEAH.
>> AND NOT A PIECE OF CRAP LIKE
THIS.
OR IF IT WAS SOMETHING THAT MOVE
THE STORY FORWARD, I WOULD.
I AGREE WITH YOU.
I SAW TRAILER AND IT HAD NOTHING
TO DO WITH WHERE PEOPLE WERE GAY
OR IN THE.
IT WASN'T FUNNY.
IT WAS KIND OF HACKIE.
BUT I MEAN, IT WAS THE FIRST
WEEKEND.
I THINK THEY'RE GOING TO DO
OKAY.
ON ROTTEN TOMATOES, IT'S GETTING
TWO TOMM
TWO  TO WANT /-* -- FOUR
TOMATOES.
[APPLAUSE]
>> I WANT TO SAY SOMETHING
THAT'S NOT A JOKE.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT OTHER MOVIE
BEAT THIS MOVIE IN ARIZONA THIS
WEEKEND?
>> WHAT?
>> MY MOVIE CALLED DADDY
DAUGHTER TRIP THAT WAS RELEASED
IN 17 THEATERS IN ARIZONA.
WE ACTUALLY BEAT THIS MOVIE.
WE WERE -- THANK YOU, GUYS.
>> ONE OF THE VIEWERS OF THE
MOVIE WAS HERE.
>> WE WERE -- FOR REAL, I THINK
IF IT SHOWS -- IT'S ABOUT THE
CONTENT AND IT'S NOT ABOUT --
YOU ALSO DON'T BLAME THE CROWD.
BY THE WAY, THIS MOVIE DADDY,
DAUGHTER TRIP THAT I WROTE, I'M
ALSO IN IT.
I HAVE A SCENE WITH MY HERO JOHN
KLEASE.
DURING THE PREMIER, I WENT TO
GET POPCORN AND I MISSED THE
SCENE.
THAT ALSO TELL US HOW MUCH I'M
IN THE FILM.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
THAT WASN'T FUNNY.
TYRUS, HE CALLS YOU FRIEND.
>> YES.
YOUR ONE OF MY CLOSEST FRIEND.
>> I KNOW YOU SAW THIS MOVIE.
I SAW A MOVIE IN WHICH THE
PROTAGONIST WAS AN ELDERLY
FEMALE ASIAN.
I'M NOT AN ELDERLY FEMALE ASIA
KNOWS AND I LOVE THIS MOVIE.
EVERYTHING EVERYWHERE AT ONCE.
IT ALSO -- THE SUB PLOT IS
LESBIANS.
AND THAT'S THE -- I DON'T EVEN
THINK OF THAT.
I JUST THINK IT WAS A --
>> IT WAS A GOOD MOVIE.
HERE'S THE THING.
FIRST OF ALL -- HERE'S THE
PROBLEM WITH THE WOKE.
THEY ALWAYS ACT LIKE THEY DO
EVERYTHING AND THEY NEVER DO ANY
RESEARCH.
IT WAS A REALLY FUNNY MOVIE
CALLED IN AND OUT.
THE FOUR SONG -- EVER HEARD OF
THE BIRD CAME?
THOSE WERE PHENOMENAL MOVIES
THAT HAD -- THEY HAD THE PLOT
WAS ABOUT BEING GAY OR WHATEVER.
BUT THEY WERE GREAT MOVIES.
THIS WAS -- LIKE ONE OF THE
LINES IN THE COMMERCIAL WAS YOU
HAD A GOOD RUN, HETEROSEXUALS.
SO IF I WAS SITTING ON THE COUCH
AND IT WAS LIKE YOU'RE ON YOU'RE
WAY OUT NEGROES, I'M NOT SEEING
THAT.
>> THAT GIVES ME AN IDEA.
>> I'M JUST SAYING.
I MEAN, I DON'T CARE WHO IS IN
IT.
IT'S NOT FOR ME.
>> THAT CRYSTALLIZES THIS POINT
IS THAT WE CAN MAKE IF YOU THINK
OF YOU AND THEN YOU DON'T LIKE
TO BE AROUND US ANYMORE.
>> YEAH.
BUT IT'S NOT MAKING FUN OF.
THAT'S THE POINT.
>> YEAH.
>> WHO HE SHOULD BE MAD AT IS
LBGTQ+ BECAUSE THEY ARE ARE THE
ONES THAT -- DIDN'T SHOW UP.
>> NOBODY SHOWED UP, KAT.
IS THAT YOUR FAULT?
>> WELL, I DON'T LIKE GOING TO
THE MOVIES.
'CAUSE WHEN I DO, THE MOVIE GET
ALL THE ATTENTION.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
IT'S HARD FOR YOU TO KEEP THAT
CHAIR DOWN.
>> IT'S HARD.
WELL, ALSO LIKE -- LIBERALS WERE
UPSET ABOUT IT, TOO, BECAUSE THE
GAY GUYS WERE WHITE GAY GUYS.
THERE WAS PEOPLE THAT WERE LIKE
UPSET ABOUT THAT.
ALSO PEOPLE JUST THINK HE'S
ANNOYING.
I DON'T THINK IT'S A POLITICAL
THING.
THEY FIND HIM EXTREMELY
ANNOYING.
>> YES.
MY PROBLEM.
>> TRUE.
ALSO, IT'S SPOOKY SEASON.
>> YEAH.
IT IS SPOOKY SEASON.
>> NOBODY WANTS TO WATCH TWO
PEOPLE FALL IN LOVE, UNLESS ONE
OR BOTH OF THEM IS GOING TO MEET
AN UNTIMELY DEAD IN OCTOBER.
>> THEY SHOULD HAVE INTRODUCED
SOME KIND OF MONSTER.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> THAT MONSTER WOULD BE DONALD
TRUMP ALL RIGHT.
I THINK